you have a new album coming out uh heart
theory which is
going to take us on on a major journey
when did you realize it was
time to tell your truth and put it out
there in music
three years ago i went to a place called
youth for tomorrow
they're an organization that um that
help a lot of kids
age 12 to 18 um specifically survivors
of
of rape and sex trafficking and i went
and sat at this conference table with 12
other little girls
and i told them my story and i heard
their story
i left that campus that day knowing that
i needed to tell my story
and so i i called up a friend of mine
miss brandy clark
who is just such an incredible
songwriter and
we wrote the song make you it's gonna
make you hate yourself
[Music]
when you write music like this which is
so
part of who you are you talk about the
anger you talk about the shock you talk
about the acceptance
where was that moment where you felt
this is a lot this is too much for me
definitely make you is a difficult song
to write i've tried to write that song
so many times and it always just ended
up sounding so deep and so dark and i
didn't want
that message to be about that you know i
wanted it to be about light and hope
um so that one you know took took a
little bit to figure out the right way
to write it
writing songs through those emotions and
truly letting myself feel those emotions
was
was a big step it was a big thing have
you let the anger go
yeah i have it
was a process and even more of a process
because
again it's not easy for me to feel angry
and so i just denied
the fact that i was even angry about it
which is
is most of the problem you know until
you can
really own that and and say
i am angry
[Music]
writing a song i feel like i'm being
able to
hold the hand of my 13 year old self and
hold the hand of my 21 year old self
and be like i got you guys
[Music]
listening to make you i'm sorry you know
i'm so
sorry as a mother talking to you right
now
um and thank you for speaking up
watching the response from this song and
and what it's
doing and how it's lifting people up and
when i have fans reach out and and say
that
you know they've never told this to
anyone before and yet they share their
story with me
and or maybe that i've inspired them to
go share their story with someone else i
mean
that's that's why we're here you know
yeah to help each other
and um i just really hope that i can
help
a lot of people and at the very least
let them know that they're not alone you
know if i would have had somebody when i
was 13 to
hold my hand and tell me it's gonna be
okay it's gonna be okay
i think i would have healed a lot faster
and so
i want to be a you know an
ally and and um just a voice for
for survivors who've been through this